the mighty Marvel Rumor Mill has just
cranked out a doozy according to the
folks that we got this covered Marvel
Studios is looking to cast a quiet place
director and Star John cinski as Captain
America or rather an alternate universe
version of cap who would appear in the
upcoming Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness on its surface
this rumor makes a fair amount of sense
after all cinsky did indeed audition for
the role of Steve Rogers roughly a
decade ago when Captain America the
First Avenger was ing production of
course the role was eventually handed to
Chris Evans who was born to play it but
there have long been rumors that Marvel
head honcho Kevin fige never forgot
about krinski and has maintained a
simmering interest in slipping him into
the Marvel Cinematic Universe somehow
ever since Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse of Madness could be a good
vehicle by which to finally bring
krinsky into the fold and according to
the rumor he may not be the only Marvel
might have been to appear in the flick
if these murmurings can be believed Tom
Cruz might also appear as as an
alternate universe Tony Stark it's long
been rumored that Cruz was offered the
role before it eventually went to Robert
Downey Jr although it must be noted that
this has been debunked by none other
than Cruz himself on that note now would
be a good time to mention that we got
this covered is not typically a reliable
source of Insider info and that when it
comes to these types of rumors the
site's ever Anonymous sources regularly
offer up some major Malarkey this rumor
is likely no different for a couple of
reasons you got to stop telling people
okay I get it you feel out of the loop
and you feel sorry for yourself and it's
really sad because everybody thinks
you're a loser do you even know if it's
true do you have any idea first off
krinski is an outspoken fan of the MCU
and he's obviously never lost his
hankering to be a part of the biggest
movie franchise in the world in recent
years his name has often been floated by
fans and Industry observers alike in
connection with one specific name Reed
Richards aka Mr Fantastic of the
Fantastic 4 even before Marvel's first
family became available for Marvel
Studio Studio's use thanks to parent
company Disney's 2019 acquisition of fox
krinski was all but lobbying to play
Richards in the MCU back in 2018 krinski
told Screen Rant that he would love to
play the MCU version of Richards should
the opportunity arise and that he would
also be pretty pumped if his wife and
quiet place co-star Emily Blunt were to
be cast as Reed's wife Sue storm AKA The
Invisible Woman more recently in the
wake of rumors that krinski and feige
were engaged in meetings in early 2012
20 krinski told sci-fi wire that he'd be
down not only to star in a Fantastic
Four movie for Marvel but to direct it
as well he said I'd totally be open to
that I love the Marvel Universe I love
watching these movies they're such a
great time and so well done I always say
in Kevin feige I trust he's such a smart
guy and I would never pretend to know
what he's thinking but if he's thinking
about hiring me I'd be psyched well then
what's the on you rumor we have a right
to know it seems just a bit likely that
after about a decade of courtship Marvel
would bring krinski on just to show up
in a glorified fan service Cameo almost
as unlikely is fige suddenly deciding
that what the MCU really needs is to
start aping its closest competitor
Marvel may have announced Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness first but
earlier this year Warner Brothers in DC
entertainment revealed plans to adopt
the concept of the Multiverse into its
films in Grand fashion in the upcoming
Solo movie for the flash which is being
directed by it Helmer Andy musetti and
we'll see Ezra Miller reprising the
title role from Batman versus Superman
dawn of Justice and Justice League The
Scarlet Speedster is canonically capable
of interdimensional travel and it's been
revealed that at the very least he'll be
dealing with two different versions of
Batman the one established by Ben
Affleck in the previous DCU films and
Michael Keaton's version from Tim
Burton's Classic Batman movies why don't
you come over and we can watch together
on TV we're Marvel to essentially copy
this strategy and introduce alternate
versions of its heroes in Doctor Strange
in the Multiverse of Madness it would be
a pretty stunning reversal from the tack
the studio has taken in the past that is
blazing its own path and leaving
competitors wondering how to achieve
similar success without openly copying
Marvel it's hard to imagine fige and
Marvel Studios are champing at the bit
to switch from cinematic Trend Setters
to Trend Chasers no this rumor feels
like one that should be filed under n
for not bloody likely somehow we get the
idea that krinski is destined for a much
bigger role in the MCU when that
announcement finally comes we'll be all
over it check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more Looper
videos about your favorite movies and TV
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the Bell so you
don't miss a single
[Music]
one